there are a few rules to follow in
traversing through the marvel cinematic
universe
the most important rule is one that's
already been long established in comic
books
death isn't necessarily final and some
goodbyes are really just
see you laters so dead brother huh
yeah it could be annoying well he's been
dead before
as it turns out that last rule will
apply to the fourth avengers movie in a
big
way it's not really a surprise that some
dearly departed heroes are making their
way back to life in the super sequel
but according to one mcu actor the
infinity war follow-up will be bringing
one villain back from the dead in a
super clever way
and if he's telling the truth the
details might just confirm a major fan
theory
speaking on the ufc unfiltered podcast
actor frank grillo revealed that marvel
fans can expect to see him reprise his
role as the hydra
agent terrorist brock rumlow also known
as the comic book villain crossbones
now you might be thinking didn't
crossbones pretty clearly die by blowing
himself up
at the start of captain america civil
war well yes he did
it was kind of a big deal with his
explosive demise and the collateral
damage it caused setting up the sokovia
accords that still affect the movie's
universe
to this day
[Music]
yeah there's not really any coming back
from that one but it's not like the
villain is returning from the grave
instead audiences will be going back to
the time before he died
it turns out grillo's crossbones will
actually pop up in what he described as
a flashback sequence
one might initially think that grillo's
remarks were just to keep the rumor mill
churning like other avengers actors have
done in the past but that doesn't seem
to be the case
grillo made a point to mention that he
can spill as many details as he'd like
since he's not tied to a marvel contract
and doesn't expect to work with them
again it sounds fair to us though we
kind of doubt that marvel producers are
all that happy about his decision to
spill the beans
the actor's exact words were i'm allowed
to say whatever i want because i'm never
doing another marvel movie
but it's not because he doesn't like the
company or the franchise apparently he's
just tired of the work it takes to be a
super villain
or as he sarcastically put it quote i'm
117 years old
at one point in the period between civil
war and infinity war grillo sounded
certain that he was done playing
crossbones for good and even implied
that he had turned down an opportunity
to return to the series
he shared those thoughts during a
january 2017 interview with collider
discussing his departures from both the
purge franchise and the mcu
in the interview he said there's nowhere
for it to go unless you're captain
america or iron man
they were talking about it but i was
like you know what i'd just rather not
do it
but apparently something happened behind
the scenes to change the actor's mind
by september 2017 the actor was hinting
at a return appearance to the series
during an interview with forbes he said
there is some marvel news that nobody
knows yet to do with my character
that's going to be really interesting
and i'm excited about that
almost a year later in july 2018 grillo
sparked even more rumors that he'd play
a part in avengers 4 when he took to
instagram and shared a collage photo of
a crossbones action figure with the
caption
uh okay i guess my life is complete
of course the first two hashtags in his
post referenced grillo's appearances in
the second and third captain america
movies but that half done
third hashtag yeah that's almost
certainly a nod to avengers 4.
on the surface grillo's comments simply
confirm what seems like a very small
plot point of avengers 4.
crossbones will reappear in a flashback
scene but looking at the bigger picture
his remarks actually seem to validate
the long-standing fan theory that the
sequel will see the surviving heroes
from infinity war traveling back in time
to defeat thanos
the theory goes that they'll be using
the unique attributes of the quantum
realm to go back into the past and
obtain the infinity stones for
themselves
effectively reversing the events of
infinity war before the battle with
thanos even begins
this theory first cropped up after fans
got a peek at avengers 4 set photos that
showed chris evans wearing his captain
america costume from the battle of new
york sequence from 2012's avengers and
has been lingering in fans minds ever
since
in that sense crossbones's appearance
will be less of a flashback and more of
a do-over
as with everything out of the super
secretive marvel studios
nothing is a guarantee until the company
comes right out and says it is
and even then it's still suspicious the
only way to know for sure what happens
is to be there when avengers 4 takes off
on may
3rd 2019